>> Good morning everybody.
Good morning copyright
experts and authors.
My name is Maria Pallante.
I'm the United States
Register of Copyrights.
It's a great privilege
and pleasure
to welcome you here
today to hear
about authors' attribution
and integrity.
My staff and I have
been looking forward
to these discussions
for a long time.
Moral rights are something
that we haven't talked a lot
about in the United
States in recent years.
And so today, this
symposium marks the beginning
of a very important conversation
that will eventually extend
to a formal public process.
I want to extend a very warm
welcome to all of our panelists
who are here today, including
those of you who have come
from other cities to be
part of this conversation.
I'm very pleased
that we'll be hearing
from a wide range
of perspectives.
Legal, scholars,
industry representatives,
and perhaps most importantly
authors, composers and artists.
I want to thank my staff for
the very hard work that went
into pulling this together
in the Office of Policy
and International Affairs,
headed by my colleague Associate
Register, Karyn Temple Claggett.
And I also want to
thank Sandra Aistars,
who's sitting here to my left.
And all of her colleagues
at George Mason University
Law School in the Center
for the Protection of
Intellectual Property.
Not only for collaborating on
this particular symposium today
but for being one of our very
important academic partners.
This is the, I think,
third academic partnership
we have along
with Stanford University School
and George Washington
University Law School.
And it means everything
to us to be able
to collaborate in academia.
As Register, I have
advised Congress
to undertake a comprehensive
review of our copyright law.
That started in 2013.
And I have noted in testimony
that unfortunately the rights
of individual authors
have been lost
in the conversation while they
should really be the focus.
Members of the House Judiciary
Committee and the witnesses
who testified before the
Committee also identified moral
rights issues.
Including attribution and the
ability of creators to reuse,
excuse me, refuse certain
uses of their works,
as some of the most
important aspects
of a well-functioning
copyright system.
The United States is, of course,
obligated to recognize
authors' moral rights
under several existing treaties.
Some, however, have begun
to question the strength
of moral rights protection
in the United States,
in light of recent and
perhaps not so recent case law.
So today, we will explore
a number of questions.
We'll take a look at the current
state of moral rights protection
in the United States, and
we'll compare our framework
with that of other countries.
We'll take a deeper look
at attribution rights
and how they are
covered under US law.
And we'll consider whether
the law could be amended
to better protect
authorship attribution.
Authors, composers and artists
will share how they value
and protect moral rights.
Issues related to how
licensing arrangements
and contracts are used
to supplement statutory
rights will also be raised.
And of course, we'll
be looking forward
to hearing everybody's thoughts
in the discussion aspects
of today's symposium.
Today marks only the
beginning of our conversation.
After we reflect on
what we hear today,
the Copyright Office will
issue a notice of inquiry,
beginning a more formal process,
including written
public comments.
Although at this
time I don't know
and won't prejudge the ultimate
outcome of these inquiries
to come, I can assure you
that, as with all of our work,
the process will be very
public and very transparent.
Finally, moral rights
have been addressed
by previous Registers
of Copyrights.
And I am very pleased
to recognize my two
previous predecessors,
the Honorable Marybeth Peters
and the Honorable Ralph Oman,
both of whom are here today.
So thank you very much for
coming and I'd like to turn it
over to Sandra Aistars.
Good morning everyone.
I'm Sandra Aistars.
I'm a clinical professor
at George Mason University
School of Law.
And I work with my colleagues
at the Center for Protection
of Intellectual Property
on copyright issues
on a day-in-day-out basis.
But I'm also the daughter
and the granddaughter
of artists and authors.
My father is a painter
and a writer.
My grandfather was an author and
my grandmother an opera singer.
Among my other relatives
and friends,
I can count many
additional poets and painters
and writers and rockers.
These people have shaped
my view of the world.
The relationship
that a creator has
with his work is
profound and personal.
I know by firsthand observation
from my very earliest days
how closely integrated
with the artist's personality
and identity his creation is.
It's not for nothing
that artists often refer
to their work as their babies.
I grew up in the thick of art.
My childhood was permeated by
turpentine fumes and the tunes
of the Metropolitan Opera
Saturday afternoon broadcast,
as my father painted in
his studio and I chewed
on the railing of my playpen.
I have later fond memories of
participating in naming parties
for my father's paintings.
He was much influenced by
the abstract expressionists,
so this was one opportunity to
let my creative juices flow,
with little to stand in
the way of my genius.
I was never one for
names like Untitled
or Abstract Number Five.
Instead, I preferred
to name his paintings,
among other things, Green Pizza.
And I don't know if my acumen
in naming work combined
with my father's good
sense of humor gave
that particular painting
a boost, but I can vouch
for the fact that it won
awards and sold immediately.
But I also remember
vividly the bonfires
that my father would hold
to get rid of paintings
that he did not feel proud of.
These extremes of
christenings and cremations
of works are part of my DNA.
But I think they're also
understandable to any of you,
even those who don't make their
livelihood in a creative world
and those who have not
grown up with same sorts
of influences that I have.
These experiences bring
into laser focus the emotional
impact creative works have
on our lives.
Whether we're the creators
or the beneficiaries
of those works.
You would think that all
of these influences
throughout my life would lead
to my having formed
very concrete views
on moral rights issues,
but that's not the case.
And perhaps that's because the
idea of moral rights has been
so foreign to us in
the United States.
In preparing for
this presentation,
I dug into the academic
literature on this topic.
And I want to quote to you
the introduction of an article
by Susan Liemer, which
aptly illustrates the state
of our current understanding
of moral rights in the US.
She writes, "In 1997, a sculptor
named Jan Martin won a lawsuit
against the city
of Indianapolis,
using a little known federal
statute called the Visual
Artists Rights Act.
The court found the city
violated certain rights
that the statute
granted to Mr Martin
when bulldozers destroyed
his sculpture
in the name of urban
development.
During the damages phase of
the lawsuit, the court refused
to award to Mr Martin the
enhanced damages available
under the statute
because, after all,
the city had been
unaware of the statute.
The Seventh Circuit had
no problem affirming the
District Court.
How is it possible
that ignorance
of the law was a valid excuse?"
So, so much for the principle
that we learned in civics class,
long before some of us went to
law school to learn it again.
That ignorance of
the law is no excuse.
This is one of the reasons why
I'm honored to be partnering
with the US Copyright Office
in organizing this symposium.
In order to take what might
be the first strides towards a
deeper understanding
of how we value
and how we implement
moral rights protections
for artists in the US.
I'm eager to hear the varied
perspectives of the speakers
and to learn from the
diverse sets of experiences
across industries
and internationally.
Whether there are issues
that would benefit
from further inquiry.
My initial perspective
is that discussions
about moral rights
encompass many
of the most compelling issues
that arise concerning
creativity in the digital world.
Indeed, some scholars
have commented
that moral rights
are really an avatar
for discussing basic
copyright tenants.
But I'm particularly
intrigued by these discussions
because by examining
copyright from a moral rights,
rather than a purely
economic perspective,
I believe we move towards
a fuller understanding
of the creator's
relationship with his work.
Before we begin today's
proceedings I'd also
like to take the opportunity
to thank numerous people
at George Mason Law
School who've contributed
to making this event possible.
My colleagues at the
Center for Protection
of Intellectual Property who
provided economic, intellectual
and moral support
for this endeavor.
In particular, thanks to Devlin
Hartline, Kristina Pietro
and Matt Barblan, my
students in the Arts
and Entertainment
Advocacy Clinic,
who helped prepare
the moderators
for these discussions.
And the members of the Journal
of International Commercial Law
who will publish
these proceedings.
Particular thanks there
go to Gabrielle Peters,
the current outreach and
symposium editor of the journal,
and Tyler Del Rosario,
the incoming outreach
and symposium editor.
To Taylor Hoverman, the
current editor and chief,
and Tanya Secor, the
incoming editor and chief.
And to Stephen Veit,
the incoming managing
and publications editor.
I encourage all of you to take
a moment today during the breaks
to stop by, familiarize
yourselves with the journal
and with the students, and to
consider submitting an article
for publication in the future.
Thank you for being here.
And thank you for contributing
your thoughts and experiences.
[ Applause ]
>> And so with that I'd like
to invite Karyn Temple Claggett
up to moderate the first panel.
And if the first panel
could please come up.
>> Our first panel today
is entitled Overview
of Moral Rights.
And I think some
might question us
in the United States
Copyright Office
and CPIP focusing a
whole day on moral rights
and even questioning whether
we actually have enough to talk
about for a whole
day with respect
to moral rights in
the United States.
Because of that we wanted
to start with an overview
of moral rights so that
everyone can have a kind
of a basic understanding
of what moral rights are.
How different countries
have implemented throughout
the world.
And exactly how the United
States has implemented them,
as well.
I'm not going to go through
everyone's bio in much detail.
You guys have that in
your conference materials,
but I'll just briefly mention
everyone in terms of their title
and where they come from.
First, I have June Besek who
is the executive director
of the Kernochan Center
for Law, Media and the Arts
and a lecturer at Columbia
Law School in New York,
where her research
and teaching focuses
on copyright and related rights.
Next, I have Daniel Gervais.
He is a professor of law at
Vanderbilt University Law School
and director of the Vanderbilt
Intellectual Property Program.
He is also editor in
chief of the Journal
of the World Intellectual
Property and editor
of www.tripsagreement.net.
Next, I have Mark Schultz.
He is the director of
academic programs and cofounder
of the Center for the Protection
of Intellectual Property
at George Mason University
School of Law.
He also serves as an
associate professor of law
at Southern Illinois University.
And finally, last but
not least, I have an alum
of the copyright office, Eric
Schwartz, who is a partner
at Mitchell Silberberg & Knupp.
He has over 25 years
of experience
as a copyright attorney,
providing counseling on US
and foreign copyright laws.
Including rights, ownership
and enforcement issues.
So we clearly have a very
excellent panel today.
To kind of give you
a basic background
of moral rights before
we go into more detail
about how they are actually
considered in the United States.
And what we might need to do to
amend or strengthen them here.
I'm going to start
off first with June.
And I know, June,
you have some slides,
so I'll put those up real quick.
Hopefully.
All right.
So the first question we have
for you is just a
general basic one.
What are moral rights?
And can you briefly
describe them?
>> All right.
I just have to say that
I love the question
about whether we have enough
to talk about all day.
I mean we're lawyers [laughter].
You know we can talk about --
in this case we even
something to say all day.
But any case, moral rights
are rights that an author has
in her work that are separate
and apart from economic rights.
They're accorded to the author
because her work is seen
as a manifestation
of her personality
and expression of
her inner self.
Her baby, as I think the
term was that Sandra used.
The term comes from the
French term droit moral,
but that term doesn't
really translate very well.
Because the word moral has
a different connotation
in English.
And some have suggested calling
them instead personality rights
or spiritual rights.
Moral rights belong to the
author, the creator of the work,
and not to a licensee
or to an employer.
They can't be transferred
to somebody else,
although in some cases,
they can be waived.
The most commonly
recognized moral rights
in the world are the
right of attribution,
also known as the
right of paternity.
But you can see why I
prefer not to use that term.
But this is the author's right
to have her name associated
with the work she creates.
In other words, the right
to claim authorship.
The second right is
the right of integrity.
The author's right to
prevent unauthorized changes
that would result in
distortions, mutilations,
or other modifications
of the work.
And then the third is
the right of disclosure,
right of divulgation,
also termed.
And this is an author's
right to determine whether
and under what circumstances
the work will be introduced
to the public.
For those of you
familiar with Harper & Row
against the Nation that,
that language is reminiscent
of how the Supreme Court
describes the right
of first publication
in the United States.
And then finally there's
the right of withdrawal.
Some countries like France
provide authors with the right
to withdraw their
works from the public,
if they feel the works no
longer represent their deepest
convictions, their
deepest beliefs.
In essence, this
right allows an author
to retract economic rights that
she's licensed to third parties.
However, it's rarely recognized
for a couple of reasons.
One is that it really
has to be based
on a deep-seated conviction,
which is probably actually
related to the other reason.
Which is the author
has to bear the costs,
and it can be very
expensive to do this.
So it's a rarely
exercised right.
Now I just want to mention
that the top two rights are the
ones most commonly recognized
around the world.
And the other two
certainly exist
but they're not as prevalent.
At least not in those
precise terms.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> So the next question I
guess is you talked generally
about moral rights
and what they are.
Can you give a little
bit of background,
in terms of how did the
concept develop historically?
What is the foundation or
basis for moral rights?
Why do people think that those
were important to have separate
and apart from economic rights?
>> I think a lot of us think
of moral rights as kind
of like an established
body of law.
But like many things, they
really developed piecemeal,
primarily in Europe
until they were codified
in the early 20th century.
There were two principal
theories
on which moral rights
were based.
The first is called
the monist theory.
And it braces the view that
authors' works are an embodiment
of their inner selves
inextricably interwoven
with other rights.
And not all of the rights of an
author are commercial objects.
Under this theory, economic
rights are really a subset
of moral rights, but as I said,
they're deeply intertwined.
And then there's something
called the dualist theory,
and both of these are
from different philosophical
lines of thought.
But under the dualist
theory, an author's personal
and economic interests
are separate and distinct,
and can be protected by
different bodies of law.
So you can modify a creative
work and you can sell it
or transfer it, but the
personality rights remain
with the author.
Now because countries took
different legal approaches
to moral rights, some embodied
them in the copyright law
but others embodied them in
separate parts of their laws.
But by the early '20s, there
was sufficient similarity
between laws that
countries began to urge
that these become part
of the Berne Convention.
Which, as you probably know,
is the principal international
copyright treaty and provides
for minimum rights and
national treatment.
And essentially what people
wanted was for moral rights
to become one of these minimum
rights that had to be included.
And I'm not going to
talk a lot about Berne.
But I just want to mention that,
in order to have moral
rights be part of Berne,
the countries had
to make compromises.
So the ones with
the strongest body
of moral rights essentially
agreed
that it would be sufficient,
if these rights were not
in a specific body of law,
whether copyright or another.
They didn't have to be
codified, but they could be
in other places in
countries' laws.
And this was done so that
countries like the UK,
Australia, could join without
it having to amend their laws,
if they believed that they
had sufficient rights.
And this will come up later when
we talk about how the US joined.
So the moral rights are now
embodied in Article 6bis
of the Berne Convention.
And I'll leave it up there,
but I know that we'll
talk about that more.
There are other provisions.
This is just 6bis one.
Just a couple more
things I want to mention.
How long moral rights last?
Well they last at least as
long as the economic rights,
but some countries
have moral rights
that are essentially perpetual.
And I guess that leads
me to the next point,
which I know Daniel's
going to discuss,
which is Berne members
vary as to the scope
and duration of moral rights.
And some of the finer points
we'll talk about later.
I think the last thing
I want to mention,
if you could just
advance that slide.
I want to talk about
one more right,
which isn't really
a moral right,
but it's reminiscent
of a moral right.
It's an economic right,
but it's considered an
author-friendly right.
And it's something
that can't be waived.
It provides that an author
has the right to share
in the proceeds from
the sale of her work,
even after the first sale.
And this is -- oh, one more.
Sorry. This is embodied
in Article 14ter
of the Berne Convention.
And we call it, in this
country, resale royalties.
And the Copyright Office
recently had a report
on resale royalties recommending
that they be embodied in US law.
One last point.
Which is that this
is a little different
from other Berne rights
because it is not mandatory.
But it is a right that countries
can grant to other nationals,
based on whether those
nationals' country allows
for this right.
So with that, I think
I'll end and turn it over
and move to the next question.
>> Yes. And I think we'll
jump around a little bit.
I'll turn it next to Mark.
Just to ask the question
about kind
of contrasting the difference
between moral rights,
as we've discussed,
and economic rights,
which is what we're
more familiar here
with in the United States.
>> Certainly.
Thanks. So moral rights are
a somewhat uncomfortable fit
within our system of
intellectual property rights.
So I emphasize uncomfortable
but not impossible.
That's because moral
rights have evolved
from a largely different
moral and philosophical ground
than traditional
American copyright.
According to legal
historian James Willard Hurst,
in matters of property, the US
has preferred dynamic rather
than static property, property
in motion or at risk rather
than property secure
and at rest.
This preference reflected
the values of a country
that seeks change and growth
over status and security.
And so this preference for
property in motion over property
at rest was reflected
in numerous departures
from European property
institutions.
We abolished primogeniture
and entail.
We disestablished churches.
We forbade titles of nobility.
And we certainly never viewed
people's status as tied
to the land like Europeans
once did in medieval times.
Americans were concerned with
protecting private property,
chiefly for what
it could do rather
than an identity it conferred or
how it was tied to an identity.
And so Americans were
largely concerned
with protecting people's
method of making a living
and their investments rather
than their status or holdings.
Now this focus on property, for
what it can do, has led many
to contend that the founders
had a utilitarian view
of intellectual property,
and this contention's
actually an anachronism.
While the founders were likely
mostly aware of Jeremy Bentham
and utilitarianism, as it
was emerging at the time,
they weren't utilitarians.
The founders' views on property,
including intellectual property,
were instead fostered in a
natural rights philosophy.
The utilitarian justification
for IP is a 20th century
development, albeit,
a very early 20th
century development.
And so the natural rights view
sees life, liberty and property
as inextricably intertwined.
And a natural rights
foundation justifies copyright
because it enables creators to
flourish, to survive and thrive,
conditioned on the need of
others to survive and thrive.
And so this focus has led
to a focus on copyright,
as a property right, that
facilitates the ability
to make a living
and to fully exploit
and commercialize creations.
Thus, copyright embodies
Hurst's description
of Americans' preference
for property
in motion rather than at rest.
And reproduction right,
the derivative works right,
the distribution right,
and public performance
rights enable creators
to secure an economic return.
And one way in which they
secure a return is being able
to freely alienate
their works to others
who similarly employ them
to survive and thrive.
So, in our system, we prefer
property rights unencumbered.
Unencumbered from the ability
to easily alienate them
because we are focused on
this ability to make a living.
And anything that encumbers
property rights reduces their
value and reduces the
ability to fully exploit them.
And the utilitarian
view similarly focuses
on property in motion.
Social utility is maximized when
the production, dissemination
and use of works is efficiently
facilitated by copyright.
Once again, property in motion.
Now under either the natural
rights or utilitarian view thus,
moral rights are a
somewhat uncomfortable fit.
They appear to represent
property at rest rather
than property in motion.
Property based on status rather
than fostering either
flourishing or efficiency.
Still these moral foundations,
either natural rights
or utilitarianism can justify.
They don't necessarily dictate
that moral rights can't be part
of our system of copyright.
You can make a flourishing-based
argument for moral rights,
particularly I think with
respect to attribution.
It certainly enables
creators to make a living.
And it certainly likely helps
them develop a reputation
that allows them to
flourish and encourages them
to fully exploit their works.
And if you're maximizing
social utility,
well that's usually easy, kind
of to tell a just-so story
about how social
utility is maximized
because creators will
be more likely to create
with these rights in mind.
And moreover, one has to
concede that we've come far
from our foundations
and natural rights
or even early 20th
century utilitarianism.
By adopting the Berne
Convention,
we've essentially embraced
a legal transplant,
and that legal transplant
has European roots.
And thus, when we look at
things like a copyright term
and other aspects of our
current copyright law,
we certainly have departed
from this natural rights base,
copyright or utilitarian
copyright,
to embrace a copyright
that does include these --
that is founded essentially on
these features of European law.
So thus, I'd say that
although moral rights are an
uncomfortable fit within
a copyright founded
on natural rights
and/or utilitarianism,
they can be made to fit.
And indeed, in our
modern statute,
we have several justifications
for copyright.
Thank you.
>> Thank you Professor Schultz.
And you alluded to the fact
that we have adopted
some European roots,
in terms of our IP system.
We've kind of become part of
the international discussion,
in terms of having standards
across the board globally.
And so my next question is
actually to Professor Gervais.
What international
standards do we have
that are governing
moral rights now?
I think June alluded to one.
>> Yes. Well, the Berne
Convention clearly is the
most important.
Article 6bis that was
on the screen earlier
has three paragraphs.
The first one is the one
that has the two moral rights
that June identified
as the most common,
and perhaps the most important,
attribution and integrity.
Beyond that there are -- in
the Berne Convention itself,
there are other moral rights.
The droit de suite that June
mentioned is arguably a type
of moral right, but there's
certainly another one
in 10bis paragraph three.
Sorry for the numbers here.
But it's essentially of
the same nature as 6bis.
So Berne is really about
attribution and integrity.
What has changed in the last --
so the Berne Convention was last
revised on substance in 1967.
And then four years later
they added an appendix
for developing countries.
But in 1971, the internet
wasn't all that developed then,
and there were other issues
that have changed a
little bit since then.
And one of the things that
has changed beyond technology
and that I really
want to underline is
that the performers'
protection level has changed.
So the Berne rights
are about authors only,
but this morning Sandra was
talking about opera and singers.
Performers have acquired
internationally the same level
of recognition as authors
in international treaties.
So Article Five of two
more recent treaties --
these names are a
little mouthful
but the WIPO Performances
and Phonograms Treaty
from 1996 has a moral right for
essentially music performers,
which is recognized
in many countries.
And the US actually is
part of that treaty.
And then -- I just
thought I'd mention that.
And then there's
the Beijing Treaty
on Audiovisual Performances,
much more recent, 2012.
Which also in Article
Five has a moral right
for audiovisual performers
we understand
that the president has sent
the treaty to the Senate.
So that's also relevant,
I think.
So basically international.
If you look at standards --
those are the ones I would
identify as most important ones.
You noticed that I didn't
mention the TRIPS Agreement?
Because it does mention moral
rights but essentially to say
that they're not
enforceable at the WTO.
I think a little later
we'll hear why, from,
I think, Eric or someone else.
>> Yeah. And so you mentioned
that essentially right now we
have three different treaties
that expressly obligate
member countries
to recognize moral rights.
The Berne Convention.
The WPPT. And the
Beijing Treaty.
How have different countries
actually implemented those
rights in their national laws?
>> Well, so that's a great
question because when you talk
about moral rights -- and both
June and Mark alluded to this --
it's a little bit like
the Zika virus, right?
It comes --
>> I guess you're going to
explain that [laughter]?
>> Well, yes.
No. But you'll see what I mean.
It, you know, it comes
from foreign countries.
Ideally it should be
entirely eradicated,
but at the very least,
it should be kept
out of the United States.
All right?
So --
>> Okay.
>> When you look around
the world, though,
you realize there are many ways
of implementing moral rights.
It's not like there's
one package and you have
to buy the one package and
say this is the only way.
So first of all, the
right of withdrawal
that June rightly
mentioned is very uncommon
in foreign countries.
And in countries where it
exists, it's very rarely used.
Because as June mentioned it --
for example, you're an author.
Your book is in the bookstores
and you want to take it out.
Well you can in France,
but you'll have
to compensate the
publisher for all the losses.
So you really have to
want to get your book
out of the bookstores.
So that right is really like
a good croissant, right?
You hear a lot about it
but you never find it.
[ Laughter ]
So that leaves the other three.
And so the right of
attribution is implemented
in several different ways.
Many common law countries
have implemented it.
And for example, if you're
obligated like law professors,
for example, by rules
concerning plagiarism,
that in a way is a
right of attribution.
Some countries have
used passing off.
And many countries that don't
have fair use but fair dealing,
have fair dealing subject
to mentioning the source
unless it's not reasonable
in the circumstances.
For example, Canada.
So that right is implemented
in many different ways.
The right of integrity --
here's the interesting thing.
If you read the debates on 106A,
which is the Visual
Artist Rights Act
that Sandra mentioned.
There was some concern in
Congress about destruction
of originals of art,
works of art.
And that's the one right that's
not in the Berne Convention.
So we're very good at protecting
that one right that's not
in Berne -- well, not
very good, anyway.
But and in fact that right
was specifically discussed
at the Berne Convention
revision.
And countries said yeah, it
would be nice to have a right
against the destruction of
originals, but there isn't one.
So the right of integrity,
though, is implemented
in several different ways.
So some countries just state it,
and some countries define it.
They'll define how.
For example, the right would
be in French, Canada would be
and again an example
that's not too far away.
And finally the right
of disclosure.
This right of divulgation
isn't that different, frankly,
from the right of first
publication, which has existed
in common law copyright
since, what?
Early 18th century, at least.
A couple of more
things, if I may.
So the things that
differ from one country
to another is waivability.
Some countries have
complete waivability.
Countries like Germany
and Austria
that have the monist system,
where the right is one package,
the economic and moral
rights are together.
Obviously you can't transfer
or waive the whole
package, typically.
But in countries that separate,
like the Berne Convention does,
the economic rights
and moral rights.
Then you have a little more
leeway as to how you do that.
There's a lot of
differences also,
so it may be the last point
to mention on enforceability
after the death of the author.
So some countries -- so
the Berne Convention says,
if you join Berne and you
don't have a moral right.
You can stop at the death of
the author, which was introduced
for common law countries.
But even if you don't and
you make them last as long
as the economic rights.
There are conditions
in some countries.
And it really depends, if
you look at it as a privacy
or interest or personality
right, I guess,
or a property interest.
And I think Mark was
completely on the point there --
and I said this was
my last point,
but the last thing is this.
Perpetual moral rights
scares people.
Well, if you look
at the actual cases.
First of all, there
are very few countries
that have perpetual
moral rights,
but let's say France
always come up.
Most of the cases fall
in the sort of title --
the heirs of Bach
or Victor Hugo.
They just can't prove
that they have the right,
so the court will very
often dismiss the case.
Not because there's
no infringement.
They don't get there.
They just say well, we're
not sure you're the person
to exercise the right.
So that's another scarecrow that
I think can remain in the field.
>> And I was actually going
to follow up on that because
that was -- it's not really
a question we were going
to discuss when we were
talking about this panel,
but you alluded to
litigation about moral rights.
And I guess one of the questions
I would have is those countries
that do have stronger
moral rights,
such as France or
other countries.
Is there a lot of
litigation over issues
of attribution or integrity?
And what type of
litigation do you see?
What are people arguing
when they're trying
to actually raise their
moral rights in court?
>> Well, there is
some litigation.
It's a small percentage.
I don't have the number
but a small percentage,
obviously of all
copyright litigation.
If you open a -- let's say
a French copyright textbook,
you won't find that many pages
on infringement of moral rights.
Very often it's a licensee
making unauthorized changes.
Or a licensee producing
a version of the work
without the author's name.
Or the author's name is so
small that you can't find it.
Those are the kind of cases
that you see, and they're easy
for a court because those are
pretty clear-cut violations.
The one case that, of course,
many American law students learn
about is the John Huston case,
where John Huston's heirs --
his wife, in fact --
was in court in France and said
you cannot show the colorized
version of my husband's movie
because he specifically
wanted it in black and white.
And the court agreed.
And so the colorized
version, as I understand it,
was not actually
shown in France.
But as you can see, those
are not that common.
Most publishers have no
interest in publishing a book
without the author's name on it.
Oh, this is a secret.
You know, Stephen King novel
but no one should know
it's Stephen King.
There's really no interest.
It's exactly the opposite.
You want to know
who wrote the book.
If you're the consumer, you
want to know who wrote the book.
The publisher wants you to know.
So there's not that
misalignment usually
between the licensee
and an author.
>> And just one follow-up.
And anyone from the
panel can join as well.
But you kind of gave the analogy
of moral rights being
the Zika virus earlier
and that the United States
should stay away from it.
I guess following up on your
point that there isn't a lot
of litigation over moral rights
in some of those countries
that have stronger or
more specific laws.
Does that suggest if
the United States were
to adopt something along
the lines of what France has
or what other countries have,
in terms of more specific
moral rights provisions.
Would you expect to similarly
not have a significant amount
of additional litigation
on those issues?
>> Well, you know the litigation
virus is not the Zika virus
and maybe there's --
>> There's another one.
>> That one here.
But so I think there might
be some test cases that need
to be brought to have a
little bit more clarity.
But frankly, many other
countries have had moral rights
for many, many years.
And again, you don't
see it all that often
because that misalignment
between the author
and the person exploiting
the work is rarely obvious
or present, in fact.
So, no I do not expect that --
actually attribution, as I said,
if you're in this context that
requires say, not to plagiarize,
your, you know, attribution
would come naturally.
Most people would find
attribution is fairly compatible
with their practice.
And integrity -- you know the
Berne Convention says honor
a reputation.
The real question's
how do you define that?
As I recall the Berne debates,
someone suggested changing
that for spiritual
interests or something.
What it shows you that countries
were not quite sure what they
were trying to get at.
But it's a fairly fuzzy concept,
so I think there's plenty
of room for the US to define
the cases as say, Canada does.
You really have to have
a very objective case.
It's not oh, my feelings
are hurt.
It's not that.
You need a lot more than
that to make the case.
So that would be a matter of
how the legislation, I suppose,
is changed to fully
implement integrity.
>> And then I think
maybe going back to June
and going down the line.
And then I have a
question for Eric.
But we mentioned
that Article 6bis
of the Berne Convention
obligates member countries
to recognize essentially
attribution and integrity.
But you mentioned that
there were other rights
that are considered
moral rights.
Why weren't those other
rights also included
in the Berne Convention?
Any ideas as to kind of why
they didn't think that they rose
to the level of the
type of protection
that it's now obligated
for the rights
of attribution and integrity?
June or --
>> Well, I'll just start by
saying I don't think the right
of withdrawal was ever
as recognized as widely,
so that's probably why
that isn't in there.
And the same might be
true of divulgation,
although it also is duplicated
in part by economic rights.
So I think that it wasn't
seen as necessary as,
you know, the other two.
So in terms of -- you know what
happened was a certain number
of countries had similarities
enough in their law,
and those laws were
on the books.
And these were the two that
were really the, you know,
the ones that prompted
people to move forward.
And that's why they became part
of the Berne Convention
back then.
>> Anyone else want to any --
>> No.
>> So we've talked a lot about,
I guess, the European basis
in Europe, and now I want
to turn a little bit more
focus to the United States.
And ask Eric how has the
US considered moral rights?
>> Well, thank you.
And Sandra injected a
little bit of personal story
into this morning's discussion.
And I probably should do
the same because I arrived
at the Copyright Office
on April 1st 1988.
Just in time to work on Berne
Implementation Act for my boss,
for Ralph Oman who's here to
assign me my first assignment.
Which was to do the first and
only study on moral rights
in the United States and which
we delivered in March of 1989.
And then to work on the
Visual Artist Rights Act.
So part of my preparation
here --
I really don't think I'd given
a lot of thought to moral rights
for some period of time.
But that flurry of activity, in
the late '80s and early '90s,
was something that I
certainly had a front row seat,
along with others in the room,
looking at Marybeth
and others here.
I schemed this as sort of
seven steps, I suppose.
And I'll be brief because we,
you know, are limited in time.
The first was what
I'll call the prequel.
Considering US accession
to Berne,
which the '76 Act was sort of
a partial step in the direction
with copyright term
and so forth.
But in 1985, the US State
Department convened a group
of experts, the Ad
Hoc Working Group --
and by the way, I've prepared
a little chronological order
of the history here.
Especially for students
and others
who may be unfamiliar with it.
And Irwin Karp and a group
of experts studied four
basic subject areas
on US compatibility with
Berne, including moral rights.
The final report was
issued in April of 1986
and reprinted in
Senate hearings.
And I've given you
the citations.
And the best way to summarize
it is to read the conclusion
of chapter six of moral rights
and the final Ad
Hoc Working Group.
And remember, their task was to
"identify those basic provisions
of US law relevant
to US adherence
to the Berne Convention and
to analyze their compatibility
with Berne" closed quotes.
Here's what they concluded.
"Given the substantial
protection now available
for the real equivalent of
moral rights under statutory
and common law in the United
States, the lack of uniformity
and protection of
other Berne nations,
the absence of moral
rights provisions in some
of their copyright laws, and
the reservation of control
over remedies to each Berne
country, the protection
of moral rights in the
United States is compatible
with the Berne Convention."
So that was the prequel in 1986.
Then came US accession for
real of the Berne Convention
for the remaining
couple of years.
US accedes on March 1st 1989.
A lot of House and Senate
hearings on the subject.
Round table discussions.
Irwin Karp and others
at Columbia Law School.
And I've given you the citations
for that of experts talking
about moral rights, explicit
moral rights under the US.
Is it necessary for the US
to amend its law to accede
to the Berne Convention?
The first -- there was by
the way a bill, HR2400,
which would have granted
explicit moral rights
to film directors
and screenwriters.
There was, in the
first iteration
of the Berne Implementation
Act, explicit moral rights taken
for the most part from the
language of Article 6bis,
the right of attribution.
And Barbara Ringer
always scolded me never,
ever call it the
right of paternity.
And the right of integrity.
And that was ultimately stripped
out of the Berne
Implementation Act.
And this was the
legislation that was necessary
for the US to accede to Berne.
And what the US did then
and often still does
with most treaties is
first we amend our law.
Then we accede to the treaty.
So this was the implementation
act, which was going just ahead
of our accession to the treaty.
The House and Senate ultimately
concluded after hearings
and consultations with US
agencies, trips to Geneva
with WIPO, of foreign
governments and experts,
that explicit new moral rights
legislation was not necessary
for Berne implementation.
And I've given you the
language from the House report
on Berne implementation and
the Senate reports from 1988.
And reading the House
report, based on a comparison
of its laws with those
of Berne member countries
and on current status of
federal and state protections
of the rights of
paternity and integrity --
they clearly had not
spoken to Barbara --
the committee finds that current
United States law meets the
requirements of Article 6bis.
And the Senate report.
More or less the
same thing but laying
out the common law principles.
Such as liable defamation,
misrepresentation
and unfair competition.
Which have been applied
by courts
to address authors' invocation
of the right to claim authorship
with the right to object to
distortion, concluding the same.
That no new rights
were necessary --
and this was important --
citing Dr Arpad Bogsch,
who was then the Director
General of the WIPO.
That the United States
may become a member
of the Berne Convention without
making any changes to US law
for the purposes
of Article 6bis.
And truth be told, Dr Bogsch
wanted the US so badly
to join the Berne Convention,
he would have pretty much said
anything for the US to join.
Remember the US was
the 89th member --
I believe that's
right -- of Berne.
And there are now
what, 160 countries.
So it was really important to
the WIPO and for the importance
and still preeminence
of Berne for the US
to join the Convention.
The House reports and the
legislation also made clear
that Berne was not
self-executing.
So that there couldn't
be lawsuits claiming
that notwithstanding Title 17
or other federal and state laws
that the US was not in
compliance with Berne.
Or that there would be redress
in federal or state courts based
on the actual language
of Article 6bis.
So sort of sealing that off,
the House and Senate language.
The ultimate Berne
Implementation Act made very
clear that Berne was
not self-executing.
But the mid-1980s -- you know
a lot of changes going on.
And the nature in technology
for dissemination of works,
especially motion pictures
and television programs.
A lot of alterations being
made for post-theatrical.
Especially for students
in the room.
Think about a time when --
really films until that time
are only shown in theaters.
And now you have the
explosion of videos,
cassettes and home-viewing.
And suddenly post-theatrical
alteration is a huge issue.
And since where the motion
picture industry is mostly
living in a work
for hire regime,
the creative artists are saying
but we've given up our rights
for these post-theatrical
alterations.
And attribution.
Yes, there are guild agreements.
Yes, there are personal
contracts.
But there's also
alterations going on.
There was the colorization
of black
and white movies,
which begins in 1986.
There was time compression,
which is the fitted
into broadcast time slots.
You may not notice but sometimes
films are actually sped up
and compressed to fit
into the broadcast time.
There was panning and scanning
to make the aspect ratio
of what's a theatrical
screen fit
onto a television
screen and so forth.
A lot of high-profile hearings.
Steven Spielberg.
George Lucas.
Sydney Pollack.
Woody Allen.
Dozens of directors and
writers were all at hearings.
If you ever -- I know that Ralph
testified at many hearings.
And usually we would watch the
entire room empty out as all
of creative artists left
the room and the House
and Senate members, while
the copyright office went
into to testify moral
rights right behind them.
It was a huge high-profile
issue at the time.
And the question was
what to do about it?
So Congress asked for a study.
One year to study technological
alterations to motion pictures.
It was Mr Castameyer and
Mr Moorhead, the House
and Senate Chair and
Ranking Minority Member.
Which Ralph and Bill
Patry and I co-authored
and delivered March of 1989.
The timing's interesting.
The US has acceded to the Berne
Convention on March 1st 1989.
We'd already acceded by the
time we turned in the study.
Take a look, if you're
interested.
Chapter five of the
study is the summation
of moral rights legislation.
And then just you know a couple
of other points in the history.
So the spinoff on the
moral rights issue,
in the motion picture area,
was the National Film
Preservation Act of 1988.
Notwithstanding that moral
rights had been taken
out of Berne Implementation
Act, directors and writers
and others went
to an Appropriation
Subcommittee Chair Sid Yates
and got an amendment to the law
to create a National Film
Preservation Board here
in the Library of Congress.
That films would be
selected to a registry.
And those films on that registry
couldn't be or would have
to have a pejorative label
that they were altered --
if they were materially
altered --
without the permission of the
creative artists, the directors,
cinematographers,
and screenwriters.
And so that was sort of a
brief moment of creation
for that industry
of moral rights.
But the legislation
had a three-year sunset
and expired in 1991.
It was reauthorized to focus
on film preservation issues,
which still exist to this day.
It's been reauthorized,
and I've been a member
of that board since 1989.
But then Congress not
wanting necessarily
to leave moral rights
behind in the US decided --
and those steadfast
in the position --
that no new moral rights
were required for Berne --
adopted the Visual Artist Rights
Act as sort of a subcategory
of PG and S works,
the pictorial, graphic
and sculptural works --
foresaw a subclass of that
and creating a right of both
attribution and integrity.
And because there was
a particular interest
on Senator Kennedy's staff
for a right of destruction,
also a right of destruction.
So after all of that and
after Berne implementation
where the industries -- and
it's not just motion picture,
magazine, book publishers
and others
and to the questions
about litigation.
I think a lot of it was the
unknowns in the industries.
Where industries
were just, you know,
you have these very
labor-intensive industries.
And the fear of --
with deadlines and the
publishing industry --
what's going to happen if
these issues arise from one
of the many creators,
photographers or others?
What will it do
to our publication
deadlines and others?
And it was just that.
It was a question
mark and an unknown.
But the feeling for Berne
implementation was we're fine
because of all the
reasons given.
But you know the courts giveth
and the courts taketh away.
And in 2003 -- and I'm sure the
next panel will talk about it --
you have the Dastar case.
Which was, you know,
at the intersection
of copyright and trademark.
Here you have a case where the
term of copyright has expired.
And the Supreme Court
in Dastar rules
that once copyright has
expired, works may be reproduced
and disseminated, even
without attribution.
The court reasoned that federal
and state trademark laws
requiring a designation
of quote unquote "origin"
pertain only to the origin
of the physical copy,
not to the origin
of the intangible subject
matter of the copyright.
So you know whatever we were
talking about in that panoply
of other rights and trademark
law Lanham Act and everything,
certainly were significantly
scaled back by that case.
And then I suppose the final
word in all of this was TRIPS.
Yes. The US felt --
the US government felt somewhat
confident in its position
on Article 6bis of Berne, but --
>> Yeah, and I was
going to ask --
and that was going
to be my question.
We talked about the fact that
we have these obligations
in separate panels.
But we didn't talk about the
fact that the TRIPS Agreement,
for whatever reason, actually
does obligate member countries
to recognize Articles 1 through
21 of the Berne Convention.
But for some reason does not
obligate member of states
to actually recognize Article
6bis, which is a question.
>> Yeah. Well, so then,
in the timeline of it all,
Berne -- excuse me TRIPS.
It more or less completed
in December of 1991,
for all intents and purposes.
It doesn't go into force
until January of '95 and TRIPS
in January of '96, although
my friend Jane and I disagreed
about the implementation
date, I remember.
But the US government's position
and others is TRIPS
is a trade agreement.
These others are copyright
conventions and agreements.
And in a trade agreement
involving trade in goods,
only economic rights
should prevail.
And though -- you know TRIPS,
like all trade agreements was
heavily negotiated, US, EU,
Japan, Australia, and
many other countries.
The US is a newly-minted
member of Berne by this point.
This is now in the early
1990, and the feeling is
that there is no
dispute settlement
in the Berne Convention.
But there clearly is
dispute settlement
in the TRIPS agreement, which
means that across the goods
and services of TRIPS --
and you've got you know one of
the TRIPS experts in the world,
Daniel here, so you know you
should be answering this,
not I -- but the
insurance policy is
so you don't have dispute
settlement on moral rights.
That is if the US is not in
compliance in a trade agreement.
And so you limit the
TRIPS Agreement just
to the economic rights.
Read Article 9 one of TRIPS.
And yes, members -- the US wants
to, and so do many countries,
import, by reference, all
of articles 1 through 21
into the Berne Convention.
But members shall not
have rights or obligations
under the agreement in
respect of the rights conferred
under Article 6bis
of that convention
or of the rights
derived therefrom.
That's Article 9 one
of the TRIPS Agreement.
So it strips out -- countries
can have moral rights,
and many countries do.
And the US, you know, by this
time does in section 104A
with the -- excuse me, 106A,
with the Visual Artist
Rights Act.
And we do with a panoply of
other rights such as they exist.
And certainly in the '90s
before Dastar, more vigorous,
let's call it, but
at least not subject
to trade dispute is the moral
rights provisions of Berne.
So that's sort of the nutshell
history of US until, as Daniel
and June mentioned, you know
you have the digital treaties
in 1996 and then the
Beijing Treaty, which has not
yet been implemented in the US.
>> Thanks Eric.
And I do want to save some time
to turn it over to the audience
to see if we have any
audience questions.
But Daniel, did you have any
-- did you want to add anything
on the TRIPS point [inaudible]?
>> Well, you -- no.
You got the official
version [laughter].
>> Did you want to add an
unofficial version, I guess?
I'm scared to ask, but --
>> Yes. It may be true the
US government was confident
that US was complying with 6bis.
But maybe not all that
confident, I suppose.
The other argument
-- I mean to say
that these are not
trade-related rights
when you can pull
movies out of theaters.
You know, as they did in that
one case in France, of course,
was the argument used by
the Europeans to say see,
it's very related
and then you know.
So it was kind of a
discussion that I think
in the end no one was going to
die in the trenches for 6bis.
And the French government
got an earful
from many people once
they showed the draft.
But TRIPS was not
negotiated on behalf of Europe
by a French negotiator but
by a Danish negotiator.
And who knows.
Maybe that made a difference.
One thing, though, is it's
a very small footnote,
but Eric said there's no
dispute settlement in Berne?
There is, but no
one's ever used it
because it's the International
Court of Justice in Article 33.
And the reason no one's -- well
first of all, the US would have
to accede to jurisdiction
in the case.
But also no one knows what
it would do with an IP case.
So no one's ever tried,
but I just thought I'd --
>> Yeah.
>> I'd footnote that.
>> No. there -- the US
would never concede --
>> Yes.
>> To the jurisdiction.
>> That's right.
And the Asphalt Jungle
case is interesting
because that happens
in '86, I believe.
The Huston estate.
And here you have
an agreement signed,
a work-for-hire language
in California.
The choice law on the
agreement is California law.
What the French television
station was going
to do was show the -- as
only the French could do --
show the film first
in black and white.
Then in color.
Then have a discussion of
the merits or lack thereof
of the color version and
the black and white version.
And the injunction was
to prevent the screening
of the colorized version by
the screenwriter Ben Maddox
and the estate of Huston.
Notwithstanding that
it was work-for-hire,
and they'd signed a choice
of law in California.
And the French court, as
a matter of public order,
rules that the moral
rights sort of override all
of the other provisions.
I think that added to the sense
whether or not streaming a film,
you know, in color or something
was that big of an issue
for the motion picture
producers.
It sort of added
to the uncertainty
about what might happen for
works that have been created.
And in this case, created
under work-for-hire agreement
and the choice of
law in a contract
that said it's clearly
a Californian law.
That raised at least the
level of fear in some
of the creative industries.
Not all, but in some.
>> And June, did you
have a extra point too?
>> Yeah. I just wanted to go
back to the point about concern
about litigation, if the US
implemented moral rights.
Now among the chief opponents
of putting moral
rights in the statute.
When the Berne Convention was
passed were magazine publishers,
newspapers and the
motion picture people.
And during the course
of the Berne hearings,
a number of international
experts said well, you know,
we have magazines, and
we have newspapers,
and we have motion
pictures in our country.
And this has not been a
problem even though we have
moral rights.
But the response
to that was yes,
but the United States is a
much more litigious country.
And I think that's true.
And I think we have to
be realistic about that,
if we're going to go ahead at
some point with moral rights.
I mean this is a country where
you can buy a cup of coffee
and put it between your legs
on the car seat and then sue
because you get burned.
And sue successfully
because you can get burned.
And I think that that
does reflect something
about our society.
So if we were to go ahead
and create moral rights
at some point broad,
in other words.
I think it's important
that they be very specific
and circumscribed.
As I think can be said
reasonably of VARA.
And you know that's just an
important thing to keep in mind.
That that particular concern
will not just have gone away
by virtue of the
time that's past
since the US joined
the Berne Convention.
>> Okay. Can I --
>> Sure. Sure.
>> So actually, I agreed
with what June said.
But so American film directors
and others are, in fact,
typically recognized as
authors in other countries.
Even if there's work-for-hire
here.
In other words, a French court
typically will not recognize
work-for-hire as creating
authorship in the movie studio.
It will recognize
first donorship,
which mean the director
still has these rights.
And some European collectives
actually that collect money
for film that is supposed
to paid to authors have had
to make some interesting
arrangements to be able
to send that money to US --
I don't even know
what to call them.
Beneficiaries.
So it's -- but the point
here is that you don't see --
at least to my knowledge,
you don't see a lot
of US film director going
around the world saying yeah,
I can sue for moral
rights infringement.
You don't see, you know,
a heck of a lot of that.
So there might be
more here, but --
and I don't disagree with that.
Actually I think I said
something along the same
lines --
>> I will just say
that with some people
and directors are one of them.
There's another thing operating,
which is you'll never work
in this town again, so
you know, it's not just
about legally what you
have a right to do.
>> I agree.
>> And attribution is so well
covered by guild agreements
and all the other obligations
that for anybody who stays
to the end of a movie
credits is not an issue.
The motion picture industry,
everybody is credited
and the caterers included but --
>> That's true.
>> But it's --
>> So it should be easy then to
establish an explicit provision
in the United States
law for attribution.
Isn't that what the
panel has concluded?
[ Laughter ]
I probably won't
ask for an answer
for that now unless we
have some additional time.
I did want to leave open at
least five or six minutes
for audience questions.
And then, if you have any
closing remarks we can do that,
if we don't have a significant
amount of audience questions.
But I think we have one there.
>> Thanks very much.
Steve Tepp, Sentinel Worldwide,
on behalf of the
Artists Rights Society.
June, thank you very much
for mentioning the droit de
suite, the resale royalty.
It seems to me that
it certainly deserves
at least honorable
mention at this conference.
And of course for those not
familiar with it, it's the right
of authors to receive modest
commission from the sale
of their works and
resale of their works.
It's particularly critical,
I think, and I'm asking
for the panel's reaction
to these observations.
To artists whose works
are valued for, of course,
their artistic merit but
for their relative scarcity
as opposed to their ubiquity.
Which is what the Copyright Act,
the latter is what the Copyright
Act most often is directed
to facilitate.
And it seems to me that
there's a trend towards the
resale royalty.
The EU has adopted it.
Australia has adopted it
in relatively recent years,
and implementation has
gone fairly smoothly.
It's now on topic recurring
on the Standing Committee
of Copyright and
Related Rights at WIPO.
We have legislation pending in
both Houses of the US Congress.
And of course, the copyright
office has issued a report,
which I think I'll end this
with, this poignant statement.
Without a resale royalty,
many if not most visual artists
will not realize a benefit
proportional to the
success of their work.
So I just offer that up
for comment-observation
on the importance
of resale royalty.
Thank you.
>> Anyone want to
briefly discuss --
>> Sure.
>> Resale royalty?
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Works of art certainly
have a special status, right?
It's like, in music, you don't
ever want to get to the master.
Or in movies, you know,
the original copy.
So that works of art,
you're absolutely
right on this feature.
That the original --
you can make a copy,
but it's never the
painting on the wall, right?
But that being said,
again, that's a right
that scares some people.
And it's implemented so, you
know, many different ways.
The typical case of course that
you hear about is the Van Gogh.
You know, the artist who sells
the painting for five bucks,
and then somebody sells it
later for you know a lot more.
But in reality, you have
typically in works of art,
you have incremental
value changes.
And so some countries
implement this droit de suite,
like basically each
time the work sells,
you pay a percentage
of the whole price.
And some countries have
only the difference
between the sale price and
the previous sale price.
There was a long discussion
in the UK about this.
So if ever this was
to move here,
I would certainly recommend
that the Copyright Office
pay very close attention
to the debates in the
UK about droit de suite.
I think they covered it right,
left, up, down, every other way.
>> Yeah. And I would just add
that our report did
mention the UK --
>> Of course.
>> And the fact that, in
the UK, they were just going
through like you
know implementation.
They had initially just
implemented it, I think,
for the life of the author.
And then they, at the time,
were about to extend
it to heirs as well.
And so one of our
recommendations was
to closely follow, kind of
once it was fully implemented,
if it actually affected the
art market in a negative way.
>> You know, it just
seems like it's something
that could and should be done.
I should caveat it
by saying everything
and nothing I've said is very
controversial this morning.
But speaking on my
own behalf and not
for the several clients I'm
noticing in the room [laughter].
But no, I think that
personally, yeah,
there should be a
resale royalty right
when you think about
works of art.
And the, you know,
the one-off sales.
And the lack of, you know,
whether it's as a percentage
or as a percentage between the
differential and the amount
that you're talking about.
As a way to compensate
those that created the work,
not those that are good at
selling and reselling it.
With all the respect to
galleries and other places
that you know there should
be some compensation.
>> I think we're
right at the end.
I guess we have time
for one last question,
and then we're going to turn
it over to the next panel.
>> Hi. I'm Carrie Devorah,
Center for Copyright
and Integrity and probably the
odd voice in a room of lawyers
to say I don't believe
in resale rights.
I think it comes
down to contracts.
You have the right
to say I'm going
to drop the contract
and if you sell it.
I don't think the government
has the right to legislate.
Other points were made
up there they really come
down to contracts.
My background is licensing.
I entered that world over 40
years ago, and I retired a bunch
of years back because
of licensing.
You need to understand there's
a global access out there,
so it comes down to artists
being taught about a contract
and the value of time, territory
that dovetails into your talent.
So I do not believe
in resale rights.
I think if someone's
going to invest in you,
they're entitled
to make that money.
Same way as a casino entitled
to make money on your win
because they provided
the machine.
>> Thank you.
>> You don't know what the
value of the work is at first.
I mean that's the
reason for renewal.
That's the reason for
copyright termination.
I mean it's you know
that the author is just
in the unknown position
at that time of first sale
because she doesn't know
what her work is worth.
She knows what it's
worth at that moment
but she surely doesn't for
the life of the copyrights.
>> And I would hate
to cut us off.
I know that we could actually
get into a long conversation
about resale royalty, but
the focus of this panel
and of the day is a more
specifically on moral rights.
So I want to thank all
of the panelists here who've
given us a very good overview
of moral rights and the basis
for our later discussions.
Thank you very much [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.